[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today was another pretty intense
one uh today on the show is Chris
Williamson he is the host of modern
wisdom podcast uh which is an awesome
podcast you gotta go check it out he
interviews amazing people and that's
actually why I wanted to talk to him
because he has collected so much
information from so many brilliant
people about psychology and social norms
and things that are changing in society
men and women and just you know I I
tapped into his fascination with
evolutionary psychology and I just
thought he would be really cool to like
back and forth kind of Riff on some
ideas and and really just dive into the
difference that's happening in the world
with men and women and what it's like to
be a man what it's like to observe the
shift in women the dating hierarchy and
how that's shifting stuff that's truly
affecting our lives and
um and and so it was cool it was a
really cool conversation and um I think
we came up with an answer maybe perhaps
a solution to all this we came to some
ideas anyway and he was just really open
and sharing his perspectives and his
experience and also data because he does
a really good job of collecting a lot of
data points enjoy this deep dive with
Chris on evolutionary psychology and if
you like this episode please hit
subscribe please hit the bell for
notifications when we have a new one
come out every week and please leave
your comments below I do really like
reading what you have to say your
perspectives and other ideas even for
guests too is always fun to hear like
someone comes on and you're like oh if
you like that you might like this so
share it below how are you today I'm
good thank you how are you that's good
you're like in Austin right
I am indeed yeah he's your you're
British right that's also correct yeah
I lived in England for a few years
where'd you live uh you can't laugh
um I lived in Milton Keynes
um
nice
roundabouts and concrete cows I get it
um there's a lot of race teams there
um so it was kind of a good central
location
um they got a bowl something Bold
American Milton Keynes bowl is that
another thing yeah yeah The Bold and
there's like a pyramid there
and the TGI Fridays fantastic yeah the
the jewel of Milton Keynes as they call
it now yes I'm from Newcastle which is
Northeast
um it's where Winter fell from Game of
Thrones is based and then uh yeah came
to Austin a year ago for a month really
enjoyed it went back home and then came
out at the start of this year and oh my
God so I felt like you've been over here
for longer I don't know maybe I've just
been watching your stuff longer and it
feels like maybe the people of Austin
feel like I've been here for longer as
well I'm not sure do you like Austin
yeah it's great yeah it's really really
cool I was there obviously a few weeks
ago for the F1 race yes I was there as
well oh did you go no I I managed to
sneak into the pit Lanes I got to see uh
uh Daniel Ricardo uh go out on his
practice slap and I got to see Lando
Norris come back in and do his
Diagnostics and so at that level of
performance up that close is wild it's
so cool being British do you like F1
like I feel like yeah massively like
we've already we've been obsessed with
it for quite a while and it's just
arriving into America right exactly yeah
I I mean it's it's basically football
soccer and F1 I mean a cricket cricket
no nobody likes Cricket's terrible like
let's not come on Fallout early on Annie
I'm I'm sorry I I'm all I have to be
honest although we did play cricket at
um Mexico City when we were all waiting
in the TV compound for our our
um bus to take us back to the hotel and
um and we played cricket and I killed it
nice you see you're basically British
[Laughter]
we're going to start off on the right
foot so so I'm gonna ask you about why
you're so fascinated with your what is
maybe one of a topic that you love and
that's evolutionary psychology I I I'm
like so interested in why people do what
they do how they act how they act
um so where did that come from like
where where did you where did the uh
flame get lit
yes I I read a book called the moral
Animal by Robert Wright and it's from
1993 and it's a book about evolutionary
psychology it's partly biographical so
it uses Charles Darwin's life a little
bit to explain some of the stuff that's
going on and it was just a really
interesting read I think for a big while
getting toward the end of my 20s is a
guy that didn't really have any of his
[ __ ] sorted and absolutely nothing I
didn't understand myself I didn't
understand the world around me
and I wanted answers uh so I started
looking to the Jordan Petersons of the
world and the Sam Harris's and the Joe
Rogan's and the Alanda baton from the
school of life's and they were great and
they gave me some really good rules to
live by but after a while I started
asking about why are things the way they
are not just what is going on but I
wanted to find out the mechanism that
was underlying that what is it that
causes people to have anxiety or
depression or why is the female orgasm
so much more elusive than the male
orgasm or why is it like all of the you
know the big questions the those are the
three main questions everybody asks so I
I wanted to find out the answers to
these things and every time that I have
stepped a little bit closer into the
world of evolutionary psychology
it just it completely fascinates me it
completely blows my head off and I love
it uh and that's my current pet
Obsession so the audience of modern
wisdom my podcast is getting dragged
along for the ride at the moment as I
keep on finding fascinating academics to
speak to well I mean that's kind of what
prompted me to want to talk to you is
that uh you've dove in so deep with so
many people when it comes to so many
like hot topics right now especially
when it comes to men and women and roles
and you know the triggering word of
patriarchy and you know uh all those
kinds of things porn whatever
testosterone and just female status and
like those are all the things I want to
talk about because they feel like you've
done such great research but on top of
like asking what you've learned I want
to know your perspective too because you
know being like the host you don't
always necessarily go so long into
diatrats about your own personal
thoughts but having such a collection of
information it just felt like we could
have a really interesting conversation
about what you've been learning so what
are some fascinating things that you've
been learning lately Okay so
I learned that men who have a dad bod
type physique which would be a higher um
deposits of gut fat
um they are seen they are judged by both
men and women as being better fathers
you think hang on a second how is it
that a guy that has a dad bod like oh
the dad bod thing is actually real but
it's real in Reverse it's not that Dad
bods are attractive it's that Dad bods
make better dads the reason for this it
seems is that both men and women look at
a guy who has a dad bod
and they see somebody who has fewer
doors open to him where he could spend
calories that he gets so if you have
some guy that's good looking and in
really great shape and that man has a
wife and or a partner ancestrally and a
couple of kids he could spend any energy
that he wants on them but he might also
be able to spend his energy chasing some
other women around because he is
sufficiently attractive to bring them in
however the guy who has the dad bod
presumably has fewer doors open to him
where he could stray from what is family
investment with regards to the calories
so men that have Dad bods are perceived
as being better fathers mostly because
they have fewer options open to them
that they could stray from their family
with
so would it be is it's very specific to
being fathers or is it more specific to
becoming fathers and essentially being a
life partner because they don't teach
them their security uh yes that's
interesting I don't think that this is
I don't think that you're going to end
up with women being more attracted to
dads with Dad bods because they see
better parental investment future
parental investment from them I think
that it's very difficult to bypass uh
desire right like you're just attracted
to what you're attracted to and this is
why when it comes to attraction people
can try and
um logically reason their way in or out
of whatever it is that they want
ultimately you end up liking what you
like and it's very difficult to change
that around this is more other people's
judgments of the father however I
definitely think that there is
an interesting argument to be made that
um
I I have a friend whose ex-girlfriend
said to him when he was getting leaner
he trains in the gym a lot and as he was
getting leaner and getting into better
and better condition that she became
less and less happy and less comfortable
in their relationship and she said the
happiest I ever was was with you was
when you were fat and the reason for
this presumably is that some partners
and this will be the same for both men
and women you know if your partner has a
glow up there is something called mate
value which is your own and everybody
else's subjective interpretation of your
value within the mating Market if your
make value starts to increase the
partner if they don't increase theirs
along with you will start to feel that
Delta between you right they're going to
start to feel you pull away from them
and they're gonna go oh no this is going
to cause anxiety especially if they've
got anxious attachment
it's just going to cause all sorts of
problems so yeah there is definitely an
argument to be made that um some
relationships can be made to feel more
secure if one of the partners is getting
less attractive or becomes less
attractive because it is more secure to
the other one what's your experience Ben
um
anyway
I have
um I don't I don't really know about
whether or not what I've done in terms
of make value has
cause problems in relationships I do
quite I try and do quite a good job of
making whoever it is that I'm with feel
comfortable so I try and compensate as
hard as I can
um but I mean there's there's so many
interesting things I learned recently
about
um the birth control pill hormonal birth
control have you had a look at much of
this about the psychological effect on
women oh my God I mean I was on it for
16 years and I'm not with any of those
guys anymore so I'm like oh [ __ ] maybe
it did make me maybe there's something
to it yeah it changes it changes uh
pheromones and so it changes who I I'm I
can't remember it's the person it's like
the girl taking it chooses differently
when she's on versus off right it
doesn't have to do with the guy it's the
girl well both it seems both um yeah so
typically when we think about men and
women you have uh women are The
Gatekeepers and men are the protagonists
right like women of the supply and Men
of the demand when it comes to sex for
the most part and this is you you know
that this is the case but because in gay
relationships there's no gatekeeper
anymore which is why gay men have have
tons and tons of sex
um
so
it seems like women who are on hormonal
birth control prioritize providers
rather than protectors when it comes to
mates so they will look for a
provisioning man one who is higher in
terms of monetary wealth and ability to
gain resources but will de-prioritize
masculinity dominance status stuff like
that
um that means that women who are on
birth control can prioritize a partner
and then when they come off birth
control find out that the things that
they prioritized aren't any longer the
things that they're bothered about
self-reports from women that use natural
cycles which is a cycle tracking app
have said that
their self-rated sexual satisfaction
with Partners if they met them when they
were on and are now off is way down
compared with women who met them when
they were off and are now still off and
the reason being that they've
prioritized for things that didn't
necessarily sort of get them excited in
the bedroom now there is a mediator here
and it's whether or not the partner that
the woman uh gets into a relationship
with is attractive remembering that she
hasn't been as bothered by his level of
attractiveness when she first met him
but that doesn't mean that she didn't
find an attractive partner she still
could have found a very attractive
partner but he was really good at
provisioning right he was really good at
earning money or doing whatever then she
gets out of this hormonal birth control
in induced stupor enters into the world
and goes oh holy [ __ ] I've got this
really attractive partner let's have
loads of sex so it basically seems that
some women had a better time and some
had a worse time but for the most part
you can have a woman that is attracted
to you on birth control comes off and
then the relationship doesn't work so
well anymore which is a bad time for
both parties I think there's so much in
that area especially with women I feel
like in various different things
that we don't know about I mean just
even the fact that you're not having a
regular cycle you're not having a cycle
you're having like a withdrawal bleed on
it I mean women just don't know that you
you know you're put on it to regulate
your hormones oh if you have a regular
period just put you on that and they're
like basically just taking it away what
was your experience of coming off it
like everything was very normal for like
six months and
um then I met someone I dated him for
about a year Health stuff got pretty
wonky after about six months hormones
thyroid all kinds of various different
symptoms gut you name it it was a pretty
it's been a pretty big roller coaster
um so I feel like it's it's detrimental
I mean probably to what level I don't
know yet it's a massively difficult
conversation right let's say that you've
got a daughter who's 12 or 13 years old
you know that she's going to be sexually
active within the next five years or
something like that so you go okay
um do I want to roll the dice with my
daughter who definitely doesn't have the
same amount of life experience about
being safe and protection and stuff like
that than I do as someone who's been
around for a lot longer uh do I want to
roll the dice by not putting her on
birth control or do I want to put her in
birth control knowing that I'm
condemning her to this very different
very unhappy psychological profile and
one of the really worrying things is
that it seems like girls that are going
through puberty who go on birth control
because their brains are at this
formative stage of development you can
lock in changes to the brain that are
irreversible when you come off birth
control okay well then let's have a like
a bit more of a philosophical
conversation about you know I've been
thinking about this myself like there's
really only a few days during the month
you can get pregnant let's calm five or
so days that are you're fertile and sex
is just something that just can happen
right it's just like you know it's like
tagged as women's freedom and Liberation
to be able to do what you want when you
want but what if what if it's a complete
like cultural reframing where it goes to
something that isn't just everyday any
day whenever you want like can't there I
I feel like if there was a conversation
and a cultural shift around how it's
perceived and when you do it like all of
a sudden like abstinence makes the heart
grow fonder imagine make it you know
when you have to make someone wait it's
so great even yourself so what if now it
just became this really like much more
like valuable rare thing it would be so
much better
are you proposing that the entire world
limit having sex to just when women are
ovulating yeah no when they're not
unless they want to have a baby like oh
right okay so you mean okay right but
what would be the reason for that other
than just for protection like what
wouldn't have to be on birth control
right so you'd be much more safe from a
pregnancy standpoint so the narrative
changes around sex to being something
that's done you know at specific times
you would now as a woman track your
cycle more you'd understand the four
cycles of your cycle men would too
because you have it in a day a 24-hour
cycle we'd be invested yes you'd
understand
we'd have to yeah because we want to get
we want to get our underweight yeah I
mean I don't know I think
it would be an interesting
an interesting experiment to try and run
but when people want it they want it you
know and especially given the fact that
women's sex drive women's desire for
more masculine men women's desire for
more dominance in men for men with more
masculinized faces all of this stuff
increases precisely during the time when
you're telling them to not have sex like
the person that gets damaged the most by
this philosophy by your tyrannical new
sex policy
is the the people that are going to be
the most damaged by this are the women
because when sex arrive is highest
you're going to say let's try and let's
try and push this down so that's going
to be very difficult but I mean here's
an interesting philosophical question
right a difficult one maybe
should women even if they're on birth
control have sex with men who they would
not get into a relationship with or who
they would not marry personally no I'm
not a casual sex person so I'd I
wouldn't and so I would say that's the
wise thing to do
um from an emotional standpoint physical
standpoint whatever I I I mean I think
that's the right way to go thinking
about the implications for this and this
is not me trying to roll back like
women's sexual Liberation right that not
only is that toothpaste not going back
in the bottle I don't think I would want
to my point is that it's an interesting
question to ask
women who have sex with men that they
wouldn't get into a relationship with
who don't who don't show those dad-like
qualities necessarily the ones where
they're a good member of the local
community they've got a stable job
they've got a good reputation everybody
thinks highly of them you know the
typical stuff that you would usually go
through when you're going to get married
or get into a relationship with someone
What You Do by lowering the cost of sex
right by lowering the price of sex as
well men have to invest less which means
that men are going to meet that criteria
for women if previously a man had to be
a contributing member of the society and
you had to have a good job and you had
to ask for your father's hand in
marriage remembering that a lot of the
time sex was held until you had you'd
been wed so you're not just talking
about waiting seven days until
ovulation's over you're talking about
waiting an entire six months or perhaps
a year and then you're gonna ask for the
father's hand in marriage and you've got
to have the Dowry and you've got to do
the organization all this stuff if you
wait that long men will meet that
criteria like men will do what is asking
of them in order to get sex and not much
more
if the price and the uh the the
requested price for sex is all of these
things making sure that you're somebody
that is contributing and has a good job
and all that they'll do it but if it's
been the right place at the right time
at the end of the night in a nightclub
they'll also do that this isn't for me
to say women are causing men to be the
lay about useless people that we know
that they can be it's just me saying
that there is an interesting ethical
question to ask about if more and more
women have sex with men who they would
not get into a relationship with
that encourages men to not be
relationship worthy in order to get sex
sex is something that drives men to be a
type of person worthy of sex and if the
price of sex is incredibly low they'll
meet that price I didn't really think
about men
reaching a certain point of maturity or
value or status well maybe status but I
I don't really think about reaching in a
high quality way other than
having money in a six-pack
but those are things those are things
let's not discount them
I think that even with that one of the
reasons that men go about trying to get
money and get a six pack is in the hopes
of getting a good partner right and the
presumption is that if I'm in better
condition if I have more money if I if
I'm more status full
then I will be able to get a good
partner like that's what ultimately it's
survival and reproduction and survival
has pretty much been sorted in the
modern world so everyone's doing mate
signaling all the time
again I I think that there are just some
interesting questions to ask around this
and obviously this all of this that
we're talking about ties into the
broader mating crisis which you'll have
heard me talk about before but for the
the people that haven't
right now it's difficult for women to
find a man that they're attracted to and
for men to find a woman that is
attracted to them right you have an ever
increasing group of high performing
women that are two women for every one
man completing a four-year U.S college
degree by 2030 women earn on average 111
pounds more than men do between the ages
of 21 and 29 what you have is a ever
increasing cohort of very high
performing women fantastic women's
Liberation Movement we needed to have
parity when it comes to Opportunities
For Education and employment
a problem that arises is that women
fundamentally want to be in a
relationship with a man who is better
educated with more money than them this
is on average not every woman but if you
were to ask women how much do you value
your partner's employment and
educational outcomes they would say
greater than a man no man is going to
turn down a 10 out of 10 physical woman
because she's unemployed however there
are many women who would turn down a 10
out of 10 physical man because he is a
layup out on the couch okay so the issue
you have is there's this ever increasing
cohort of high performing women but
there are never decreasing cohort of
ultra high performing men that are up
and across from them so you could call
this the tall girl problem right
everybody has a tall girlfriend if
you're a six foot one woman without
heels you're looking at professional
athletes because on average most women
want to date men that is as tall or
taller than them you could see this
basically being the same when it comes
to employment and education most women
on average want to date a man who is as
educated and as employed as they are or
more
if you have an Ever decreasing group of
ultra high performing men this means
that they have a huge opportunity to
just chew through this entire Market
here they can they have a wealth of
options so they don't need to settle
down because there is a constant
conveyor belt of women going after them
the stats on Tinder bear this out that
the bottom 80 percent of men are
competing for the bottom 20 of women on
Tinder and the top 80 percent of women
are competing for the top 20 of men so
this means that most men to most women
are effectively invisible and most women
to a small number of men are effectively
usable
so are you saying that this is a shift
in
um
culture with um pay with
um jobs with status and
and it's just like a a sort of like a
byproduct of of things or is it that men
aren't actually attracted or that women
aren't actually attracted to these men
is it something that's just happening
naturally and so it's creating this sort
of disharmony because I definitely am
very curious about this whole idea
around uh you know mating and how women
essentially like mate up later like
laterally and up and men are laterally
and down and so I'm like and the more
successful the more status the more
intelligence a woman has the less likely
she is to be in a relationship to stay
married
I'm I'm [ __ ] so I really am curious
about this scenario
yeah uh again I I don't mean to try and
put a downer on how achieving women
there's no reason that they should hold
themselves back from doing this but it
is there is a difficult situation you've
got going on here it's hard for men to
raise themselves up because it seems
like women outperform men in education
and employment when they have the breaks
taken off the only reason that we seem
to have male superiority in the past is
because women had the breaks put on them
if you look at education outcomes in
school women outperform boys that
straight up outperform boys there are
some subjects in which boys outperform
girls but for the most part they don't
you could argue that that's due to the
way that assessment is done that we
should look at trying to have schooling
done in a different way it should be
more active and so on and so forth but
there are huge problems right like girls
just straight up outperform boys that
means that education outcomes are going
to be difficult to bring back down
without them putting the brakes back on
women but you can't get around the fact
that on average women want to date a man
who's more educated than they are the
same thing goes for employment
especially when you consider the
educational outcomes open the door to
employment opportunities right exactly
so what needs to change to make it work
is it a male perception thing
or is it yeah the problem that you have
here and I don't like I'm trying
not to sort of lay the blame at the feet
of women the issue that you have is that
women are The Gatekeepers to sex yeah
and what that means is that it's women
who ultimately choose the men men don't
choose the woman on average now yes
there are there are some issues that you
have amongst for men generally that the
number of men reporting No Sex in the
last year has tripled from 8 to 18 uh
sorry eight to Twenty Eight percent over
the last 10 years so if you see a man on
the street
pointing at them one in three of them
hasn't had sex in the last year that
study finished in 2018 before the
pandemic it honestly wouldn't surprise
me if one in two if half of the men that
you see on the street under the age of
30 haven't had sex in the last year so
you go well that's not very good but
it's not great for women either like
women here in this situation also need
Partners in a monogamous Society it's
one to one right so if you don't have
good quality well
viable men in women's eyes that means
that women don't have viable partners
for themselves and this leads to stories
about like where all the good men are
like R female dating strategy subreddits
come about and stuff like that
I don't think that it's particularly
good for women either in terms of what's
driving it you have this change in terms
of the power dynamic between men and
women uh the ability to get status
resources and employment and this has
started to switch another element is a
globalized sexual Marketplace that
previously uh if you were a woman you
would or if you were a guy you would be
competing with the other men for this
particular pool of women
within your village you know there was
maybe 300 eligible people and 150 of
them were guys in 150 of them were girls
but as soon as you globalize the sexual
Marketplace any girl with an Instagram
account is now fair game for any guy
with an Instagram account so you open up
this sexual Marketplace which further
means that those turbo Chads at the top
the absolute super performing guys that
are the eight out of tens nine out of
tens ten out of 10 guys they can further
capitalize on their High status
employment and education because they
can access not only within their
geographical area but they can access
the entire world that also means the
women who are quite rightly they see
this high value man who is going to
speak to them why wouldn't you accept
his advances or at least his message and
start talking to him the problem with
this situation when you add in the fact
that sex has become decoupled from
having emotions and that the sexual
Revolution meant that people didn't need
to wait till they get into a
relationship or to be married in order
to have sex
is that some men will sleep with some
women without having any intention of
getting into a relationship with them
right after that that can create a
skewed perception of mate value in the
women that suggests well hang on I got
this turbochad 10 out of 10 guy before
for one night a couple of months ago I
need to hold on until the same value man
comes along again so that I can get into
a relationship with him that's a failure
of cross-sex mind reading in that they
didn't realize this guy was prepared to
have sex with them but wasn't
necessarily prepared to get into a
relationship with them so the whole sort
of milieu that you end up with with this
mating crisis is a bunch of resentful
men right at the bottom uh they are
retreating from society they're watching
more porn than ever they're playing more
video games than ever you have a large
cohort of women who have been scorned by
moderate value and high value men
they're resentful of men generally they
Retreat into careers they work at jobs
they don't like to buy shoes they don't
need to impress people they don't care
about they commit themselves to a life
of Korea not that that's something which
should be bad financial Independence is
really important however
a lot of the time you just need to read
the articles on the internet to see that
that's done with resentment rather than
with love it's done as like a middle
finger to the patriarchy rather than I
genuinely want this and then you have
this group of guys at the very very top
and all that they're doing is just cap
like completely uh conquering and
capitalizing all of the opportunity that
they get from these women I don't think
that it's particularly good for anybody
and uh that is the problem that we've
got with the current Dynamics in The
Mating Market I'm wondering if there's a
sincerity to all that and I'm wondering
if a man really is okay with a
attractive 10 out of 10 woman that
doesn't have
a lot of success or drive and or
intelligence perhaps like what does a
man actually want
it's a good question
um
the data definitely suggests that men
are less concerned with uh employment
and education prospects amongst women
certainly less so comparably than women
if you have a I mean this is the joke
about Dan Bilzerian right that Dan
Bilzerian spends all of this time with
these fantastic looking girls and it
looks great on Instagram but he then
does need to sit on a 12-hour plane
journey to Bali while they're all
comparing nail colors or something and
you know I'm sure there's some phds in
the room but there's also probably some
you know less engaging conversation to
be had amongst those girls
um
it's difficult to look at the
um values that men have because the
number of men that have opportunities to
date a 10 out of 10 girl who's maybe not
as funny or smart as she should be
or as you might like that that's a
relatively small cohort so it doesn't
it's not really going to change the
situation too much you could ask what
solutions could men do in this situation
and they could definitely look at dating
older if men one of the imbalances in
that women often date up and across in
terms of status and resources and
education men often date across and down
in terms of age and no one really wants
to point the finger at men and say have
you ever considered just dating like
four years older because
I'm 40. I get it I agree
well look that that wouldn't that would
fix a lot of people's problems
um from the men's side but you know
people don't want to give up what they
want to give up and then you run into
men Peter panning their way through life
until they're in their 40s and then
they're like ah fine now I'll think
about settling down and having kids and
that just doesn't work with a 40 50 year
old woman yes that's true I mean I don't
see how technology and science can't
evolve but biology still exists I'm sure
that you saw that new story about
Leonardo Dicaprio and it's the age of
his girlfriends so at every time that
his girlfriend gets to 25 Leonardo gets
rid of them and gets a younger model and
then they hit 25 and he gets rid of them
and it's just he's been doing this for
two decades now Leo's into his 50s and
is still dating 24 and 25 year olds yeah
precisely
um so it's it's a it's a difficult one I
mean you know you're a data point so I'm
really curious like what is it like what
as you as a as a data point what what is
a guy really looking for
okay
um in my opinion
I'm looking for a girl who is agreeable
who is
um collaborative who is feminine
um I need someone that I can have a
conversation with I need someone who is
well humid uh they need to be
stable psychologically they need to have
trust and they need to
be prepared to grow and change together
none of those things I mean all of the
other stuff in order to get through the
door you need to have physical
attraction you need to have
compatibility of interests and stuff
like that but those things you're not
you're not even going to begin dating
somebody without those the psychological
stability the ability to grow the
agreeableness the and the agreeableness
I don't think is across the board I
think that that's more a quirk of my
personality
um and is that because you're highly
disagreeable
moderately disagreeable yeah
um and I think that it works well if you
have two discourable people it just ends
up being arguments all of the time
what about you so what what's what do
you look for in guys
um yeah that's a good question
um I mean I look more towards how I want
to live my life as opposed to the guy so
like my sister would joke she's like do
you even have a type and I'm like
because they all look different it's not
as though there's the appearance plays a
huge role
um but and I think trauma plays a big
role like we tend to attract to the kind
of person that's trying to invoke
something to correct and heal something
that is broken within us something that
is something that happened in our
childhood where we were wronged by a
parent and then we go into our dating
life and we try and right that wrong
with someone over and over and over
again so I definitely have a type of
that until of course I've done a lot of
work to figure those Dynamics out but I
attracted a very similar kind of
personality
um
but I mean even if we're talking about
pertaining to like specifically the
areas we're talking about I've never
really cared about that money that much
I mean I paid for everything in my first
couple relationships
I mean I was married at one point I mean
I I paid for everything and
um it didn't bother me that they didn't
really I mean I think now I have a
little more perspective and I see how
messed up that is
um but why do you think it's messed up
dinner really like can't buy dinner you
know like oh it's not you chose to it's
that they couldn't no it's not that they
even couldn't they didn't
uh okay yeah that's a difference well
there's some interesting stuff you know
as you as a high performing woman with
uh more disposable income than many of
the men that you're dating that's a
difficult one as well because there is
some data to suggest that if you are in
a relationship where the woman is the
primary Breadwinner there's a two times
increased risk of divorce there is a 50
increased risk of the men having to use
erectile dysfunction medication
all of this yeah true there is uh
self-reports of lower sexual
satisfaction from women there is
self-reports of lower levels of orgasm
during sex from those same women and
this is you know again all of this is on
average this isn't to say that there
can't be people there are like tons and
tons and tons of people that break this
rule the point is you as a high
performing woman have the tall girl
problem you go okay like I can either
try and find a man who is
um psychologically very
uh robust and capable of dealing with me
in this position and I am also capable
of being of having this difference
between where I am in terms of my
earning potential and where he is
um but you could imagine let's say that
there was a a girl who massively valued
uh resources in a partner hugely valued
resources in a partner but also happened
to be a multi-millionaire and you go
this is going to be very difficult for
you because what you desire and the
lifestyle that you've set up have
created such a high bar that it's going
to be unbelievably difficult to get over
what it sounds like with you is that you
didn't care so much about somebody who
was able to match your earning potential
but just didn't want somebody who was
maybe uh taking the piss if you were
able to do that that that's fine it's
about finding the right guy I think
about finding a guy who can
deal with
not being the breadwinner and that's
where it comes into
um another element as well that
men a lot of the time need a growth
mindset just as much as the women do
because they need to be able to adapt if
more women are going to out earn men
need to be able to adapt to this
situation as well as women right
relationships are a two-way street
absolutely it's easy to sort of lay the
not the blame but to lay the choices at
defeated women because again ultimately
they tend to be the sexual Gatekeepers
and Men of the protagonists
but still like if you get past that it's
on the man to be able to keep this
working because he may be able to become
resentful you don't know where this
divorce stuff comes from you don't know
whether it's lack of sexual satisfaction
comes from is it from the woman or is it
from the guy who's resentful is it from
the guy who doesn't decide to look after
himself
yeah so what um there's so many
different ways to kind of unpack it what
is it that gets triggered in a man I'm
I'm I'm putting words in into the
situation but I'm guessing that there is
something triggered within men when a
female out earns them or has more status
and so
um for sure a woman needs to understand
why she doesn't find attraction in
someone that isn't successful like look
a little deeper honey have a
conversation with them whatever those
Solutions are to rectify that but from
the male side what is it that it's
activated when you when he's in that
situation so this is a really good
question and it's not as far as I'm
aware it's not being studied
particularly well in the literature and
this is because of what we said before
that it's presumed that men will get
whatever they can get and that women are
always the ones that are making the
choices I actually do think that there's
a very important question to be asked
around what is it that um women who get
into relationships with either lower
status or lower earning men what is it
that the men are not doing I can only
speak from extrapolating my own like
internal inadequacies and and senses of
of sort of discontent and stuff in
relationships
I think that there would be a natural
sense of being emasculated by your
partner that look I'm supposed to be the
breadwinner uh you know
men want to feel powerful I put this
tweet out from a friend earlier on today
Adam Lane Smith is great psychotherapist
and he said that depression in women a
depression in men is often treated like
depression in women instead of making
men feel powerful and capable they're
made to feel heard and loved men don't
need to feel heard and loved they need
to feel powerful and capable and the
problem is if you're not the powerful
capable one in a relationship
you can end up feeling resentful you can
end up feeling uh inferior and I think
it it it triggers a lot of uncertainty
around well what is my role and you
could say that this is filtered through
a lot of culture you know what is it
that you see men doing whether it's in
erotica novels or Hollywood films or
whatever like it's guys that go out and
protect and provide yes we're not
killing wildebeest and dragging them
back to a cave but it's the modern world
equivalent of that right yeah and
without that role
what is my job like stay at home dad who
hasn't retired because he made millions
and millions of dollars there is no
unironic portrayal of that in culture
for men you know right like there is
absolutely no when you think about a
good father even if you ask people about
what it means or what they would judge a
good father to be it would be something
like um he goes out he works hard for
his family he protects he is Honorable
hang on hang on hang on none of this has
got to do with being a father like the
mother would be caring she would look
after the children she would pay
attention all that stuff like fatherhood
is a being a father is a function of
doing things in the real world that
provides for the family at home being a
mother involves being at home or at
least that's how culture kind of
currently sees it
um so I don't think that there is a
preset archetype for men to go into that
doesn't involve protective provider and
unfortunately
there is some evidence that's come out
recently that shows that female
hypergamy which is what we were talking
about before it's that tendency to date
up and across in terms of make value
female hypergamy appears to be going
down
slightly but it is going down exactly in
line with female only infidelity so
women it seems are prepared to get into
relationships with men who they perhaps
wouldn't usually but they'll only do
that if they're able to sleep around
outside of it and the reason that you
know that these two things are linked is
because male infidelity isn't going up
in line with this again you could debate
the data and all this stuff but there is
a third element to this and this is
where it gets kind of uncomfortable
because women date down a little women
perhaps a little bit less comfortable in
the relationship so they try to find it
another outlet outside of that
there is a inline increase in domestic
abuse from men to women again this you
can see how this Cascade could happen
right woman dates with guy who's perhaps
a little lower than her usual mate value
woman is unhappy she starts to look
around outside partner begins to realize
this starts to apply pressure and goes
from a benefit affording to what's
called a cost-inflicting mating strategy
so rather than trying to get the partner
to love them because they love them they
try to bring down their mate values so
that they need them right and this is
where you get cases of domestic violence
and and like drama bonding and all the
fun [ __ ] I think roles should even exist
I don't think that it's possible to get
rid of them I think it's very difficult
to get rid of a
because when you when you think about
roles for the most part they've emerged
from something that existed relatively
naturally in any case you know we're
talking about the protector provider
stuff yeah uh culture sometimes runs
with it and and takes the piss but it
needs to be sufficiently believable in
order for people to relate with it when
you try and push culture too far people
just don't relate and it doesn't work
for instance they tried to put um during
the early 2000s mid-2000s after the
um 50 Shades of Gray novels came out
they tried to Rebrand men on the front
cover of dark romance and they tried to
create an image of a softer more gentle
more feminine style man they didn't sell
nobody was buying them so you can try
and bring Fabio back yeah precisely you
know uh you can try and push the roles
as far as you want but up until a point
when in which they break because they're
no longer believable
would it be better if we had no roles
and everything was a blank slate well
you're then dispensing with all of the
Acquired and accumulated wisdom of
culture for the last 10 000 years that's
probably not a great idea do they hold
people back yes do they create
expectations absolutely
I don't know what the solution is
um with regards to that it would be
easier if people were able to start from
scratch
but you don't you're inevitably wrapped
up in culture and because the only time
we've ever done modern psychology has
been during this cultural condition you
don't know how much of human nature as
we know it through psychology now is
cultural conditioning masquerading as
natural human nature like you could
imagine that most of the stuff that we
know and and understand about humans
could be cultural conditioning that
we've never got to split test this is
why it's important to go and do there's
the Yama Mama tribe and a bunch of other
um still hunter-gatherers maybe like a
couple of hundred of them left
you can go and do studies on them and
that is the that's the split test it's
like okay does it does it exist in those
as well but yeah I mean so maybe it's
better than ever maybe it's better than
ever
how well I mean if I think in ancient
times whether it's Roman or Greek or
Egyptian or you know there was a point
in time I think in in Far Far More
ancient history where women actually did
play an extremely like high role in
um in culture but there's a lot of
tribal situations where
the men go and get the food and they
build the house homes and they provide
and women are the nurturer and they
you know some of it is obviously a lot
of it has to do with practically
physically like you said it's what makes
sense it's like
you know if we're really looking at it
from a basic standpoint it's like I'm
not gonna go slay the dragon like if I
have someone that's much taller and
stronger than me that would make sense
so there's much more equality going on
for things
in the world so in some sense it's
better than ever I would say that it's
difficult to go back in time and find a
an era where humans haven't been as
safe secure
comfortable as they are now the problem
the problem that you have is that
Comfort is not necessarily what makes
people happy that
um we are living the most comfortable
and secure life ever but we're also
living a life which is the least like
the one that we grew up in ancestrally
you're spending less time outside you're
spending less time in groups you're
spending less time around partners and
potential Partners less time under the
sunshine in nature you're eating more
processed foods you're drinking less
water or you know just pick the thing
that would have been adaptively used for
a very very long time to have a good
life for your ancestors and most of them
have been worked out our sleeping
environments are different our sleep and
wake Cycles are different the way that
we consume food and water is different
the type of substances that go into our
bodies you know just everything is very
very different when you think about
Maslow's hierarchy of needs at the
bottom
food safety security shelter so on and
so forth
having an existential crisis that a lot
of people go through why am I here what
is the reason for this should I get into
a relationship or move to another
country start a family have a career
these are very luxurious problems to
have they don't make them any less
painful when we Face them but the fact
that you have the opportunity to ask
this question is a byproduct of the fact
that life is so good for us at the
moment but
that doesn't make dealing with an
existential crisis any more enjoyable it
still sucks it's still really really
painful but what do you want to do you
want to say let's roll back all of the
advances that we've had in medicine and
in climate control and everything in
order for us to live a life which might
be completely brutal and at the mercy of
the Wilderness but at least I wouldn't
deal with my existential crisis anymore
but also probably not a particularly
good position to be in makes me ask you
a question that's kind of just more of a
simple broad what's not simple it's a
broad question but what is what is
innate to our human existence as far as
challenges go what is part of this game
social relationships would be probably
one of the big ones that's changed I
would say the way that we relate to
other people in that typically we would
have been constantly permanently exposed
very intimately to a lot of other groups
even up until a few thousand years ago
you would have lived in pan generational
houses right it would have been you with
your kids with your parents with your
grandparents you know in one Hut or
whatever right so
even in relatively recent history things
would have been very different socially
I think the food that we're eating I
think the the way that we're interacting
with nature I think that that would be
what's close to innate
I don't want to skip over this topic I'm
very fascinated about it
porn
okay
I had no idea it was an epidemic I have
a funny porn story
I was asked by this friend what's your
favorite porn search it was like sitting
at a dinner with another friend and it
was two girls and a guy and he's like
what's your favorite search engine for
porn and I was like like in Google
and he was like no he's like do you not
watch porn I'm like no and so I was
proceeded to then go watch two girls in
a cup and of course I never watched
again I had no I had no idea that every
guy watched it and lots of girls watch
it I just didn't I I did where does this
come from and you know I joke I'm like
you know girls don't act like that like
if guys start watching that young like
there is not much about that that's real
why do you think that you don't watch
porn
it's so fake
I mean it's not that I haven't seen
moments of it of course but it's so fake
there's nothing about it that
um is real it's raunchy it's
um not practical it doesn't feel good
for that long there's no way
um it's disrespectful in some cases
do you read like erotica or listen to
erotic books instead okay right
well I think that
porn generally is very novel that a man
can see more naked women in a day than
he would have seen in his lifetime
previously again we're talking about a
male adaption we're unfit for purpose
ancestrally with what we are used to to
what we can have access to now
um how young does it start can I just
ask that one question and then go ahead
like how young does it start for men
or boys uh I don't know because this is
quite novel that porn has been as easily
accessible from as young as it is now
you know if you if you were to think
about how hard it would be to get hold
of a Playboy magazine 20 years ago it
would have been pretty difficult
um
whereas
I'm sure that the right iPhone Parental
Guidance control workaround hack that
almost every 14 year old on Tick Tock
probably knows about they can probably
get access to whatever it is that they
want
um so there's probably a ton of data
that needs to be mined from that but I
mean like
as soon as boys hit puberty they're
thinking about sex that's all that
they're doing that like they don't even
know what it is and they're thinking
about it
so
I
I wonder what the long-term effects of
porn are going to be I don't think that
it's particularly good
but remember what we said earlier on
about that group of men that are
retreating from society into porn and
video games right yeah
there's something called young male
syndrome and what that refers to is
typically in a society where there is a
surplus of young unmarried men
uh you get instability you can imagine
why because these guys have no ties to
the local community why should I behave
why shouldn't I run around and cause
havoc and push over granny why shouldn't
I I can do what I want
um I I don't have a partner when men get
into a relationship the testosterone
drops when men get have children their
testosterone drops again as well like
that's biologically what's going on but
even just culturally you understand I'm
going to get in [ __ ] off my wife and of
her father if they find out that I've
been you know burying things in such and
such as garden and causing Mischief I've
got to behave
one of the questions that's being asked
at the moment is given that we're seeing
highest higher than ever rates of
sexlessness amongst young men
why hasn't young male syndrome occurred
that's not to say that we haven't had
some in-cell shootings there have been a
few but they're very few and far between
significantly less than what I said
earlier on nearly one-third of the
population of men between 18 and 30
having had no sex in the last year
probably more now
why hasn't young male syndrome kicked
off and one of the potential reasons for
this is that men are getting fake cues
of Fitness signaling from porn and video
games so video games gives them the
sense of camaraderie of goal setting and
achievement that you would typically get
from going and hunting down some sort of
animal okay so that that gets rid of the
kind of forward progression uh and then
porn is giving them a very very small
titrated dose but sufficient to keep the
sexual desire at Bay so you could look
at the men that are kind of being
lost by the wayside at the moment as not
going out with a bang but instead going
out with a fizzle that you're not going
to see they're being they're being
sedated out of misbehaving and a really
difficult question to ask is would you
rather have miserable men that are
sedated or capable men that are causing
havoc
like that's an uncomfortable situation
to be in
um
so it's kind of helping in some way
there's
it's providing a function
yeah and the question is
does it matter to benefit is it is it
better overall would you rather have
which of those two societies do you want
do you want the men sedated into this
sort of
like gray goo metaverse existence
Cheetos mum's basement thing or do you
want the guys and they're going to make
less less good partners but they're
significantly more stable it might have
just been something else in the past yes
um I think it would have been difficult
before porn to bring it back to that
conversation about
would have been really hard to have
found an outlet that would have give
given men sexual satisfaction
sufficiently uh to be able to sedate
them from causing disruption without
like the ever increasing stimulus that
porn gives you basically an endless
library of of stuff that you can get
um
acclimatized to but even with that you
have rates of uh increases in rectal
dysfunction because when men
specifically watch porn their brains
don't quite know that they're being
conditioned not to learn to get aroused
when they watch other people have sex
when it comes to getting one-on-one with
a girl that doesn't necessarily mean
that it's going to transfer over
Andrew hubeman uh neuroscientist taught
me about this that he said it it can
cause issues because of how you
condition your mind to learn what
arousal is so like men could literally
be conditioning themselves into being
voyeurs and I mean I don't think that
that's what they wanted when they
started watching porn but if you are
struggling to find a partner if there's
a pandemic for two years
what do you do it seems you know it's
interesting for you to say that um
in terms of stimulus you don't there's
no
PornHub membership there's no 50 Shades
of Gray by the bedside table
um
for men
that would be almost Unthinkable right
the the level of sex drive that men have
is is basically
women who've gone transitioning women
female to male who go on testosterone
have said that they're shocked and
appalled at what testosterone does to
sex drive I've heard like they just
completely cannot believe it uh I think
the the story was
uh when I was a female I could choose to
masturbate now I'm a male I have to
masturbate that was how that was how
they saw it um and
it's
it's a difficult one men and women
aren't the same they're not the same and
that means that you need different
solutions for different people tell me
talk to me about kind of the struggles
right now like I just feel like it's a
really interesting time for men what are
some of those challenges right now I
think
the biggest concern is for me is trying
to find a solid place for masculinity to
stand like what it means to be a man
um because
the media at the moment is telling men
that
in order to be a better man they need to
be more like their sister
but history throughout all of time told
men that to be a better man you had to
be more like your father so you go okay
like what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to be the protective provider
or is anything that I do toxic
masculinity like toxic masculinity is a
term now which has become so diluted it
doesn't mean toxically masculine
activity it means anything masculine
that we find objectionable it's for
instance there was a story that came up
in Richard Reeves book where a group of
boys in a school had decided to make a
note on someone's phone rank ordering
all of the girls in their class by
attractiveness now is that uh like
uncouth Behavior yes is it toxic
masculinity
I I would hesitate to say that it's
toxically masculine it's like something
that it's what Facebook was literally
built on I was just gonna say this
sounds like Facebook yeah that's that's
actually the the uh original website
what was it called like rate rate my
face or whatever it was yeah yeah before
Facebook that was what Mark Zuckerberg
created it on yeah no one's pointing at
him and saying that you're a toxically
masculine thank you
things about him nowadays and they are
saying a lot of things about him
it's a difficult time at the moment I
think because
men are struggling to find a solid place
to stand they don't really know what
they what they can do that will give
them honor it's very easy to do
something which takes your honor away
from you and what we've created is a
situation in which men and women see
each other as enemies fundamentally and
that's the main concern that I've got
like the the big problem and the big
riff that I would like to try and fix is
that men fundamentally compete with
other men and women fundamentally
compete with other women
they've worked together for a very long
time most simp shaming comes from men
more [ __ ] shaming comes from women like
most of the
pro-life campaign comes from women not
from men it's not men that are trying to
control that but most of the criticisms
that derogate men in terms of their
appearance and their sexual prowess and
all this stuff comes from the call is
coming from with within their own house
how can we get a good
high quality role model
where men can can work out a way that
makes them feel honorable and virtuous
and attractive to women
that's what I think is missing mostly
well there's definitely a call by women
for men to get more in touch with their
feelings to be able to open up more like
women are craving a connection that goes
beyond just providing we want emotional
connection so there is an Ask being made
for sure
um so it kind of leads me into being
curious whether or not uh you
think about even
the balance within you of what would you
know in the spiritual world would be
called Divine masculinity and divine
femininity and that we all have both
within us and I think that women are
happy to step into our masculinity and
to be able to go yeah get that job and
ask for that promotion and you know
don't stand for that and stand up for
yourself and be able to be on your own
two feet and make a good income and not
have to rely on a man and not be at the
mercy of somebody else like there's a
lot of that that's okay so I'm curious
if that's something that men in general
I'm sure you have a lot of friends and
or even yourself like do you think about
that and how do you
practice that balance or engage and
activate the the femininity within you
to bring that balance to answer the call
it's difficult to try and find a place
as a man to like Embrace femininity
right especially because of the way that
you grow up that it's status
competitions between you and other guys
um it's very rare that other guys are
going to tell other guys that they need
to be more feminine hey man you should
really embrace yourself think about that
hair is doing it Harry's doing it but is
he being encouraged by the men around
him to do that good question I I I would
guess not
um I think one of the concerns that men
have when it comes to embracing their
feminine side
is that
they have limited evidence that that's
truly what women want that's not for me
to say that that's not what women want I
think that a man that can open up that's
emotionally stable that's able to
actually talk about these feelings and
emotions the world of my grandfather you
know engineer that would come home and
smoke and see about whatever problem it
was he had at work and never speak to my
grandmother about it that that those
days have gone but remember what I said
about the front cover of erotica novels
right there is a
we are uncertain as guys that women will
want what they see if we open up to them
if we're vulnerable to women
and they don't like what they see then
not only have we now opened ourselves up
but we've also lost the girl
hey I I am all for showing the feminine
side I I wear pink you know I can pull
off pink I'm I'm all for it
I agree I've said that for a long time
it's it's a very difficult one for guys
to to deal with because
at the same time as men are being told
to open up they're also being told to
man up about their emotions and that
trying to balance both of those things
together
is is a bit of a difficult one
what would make you feel comfortable
what would be the environment that would
make a man feel comfortable to share
what's going on it doesn't have to be
with women necessarily it can be but
like what are those circumstances that
would give you comfort to be able to go
into some spaces that you haven't been
before
you definitely need trust I think you
need to be able to trust who it is that
you're with um I personally for me I
have I'm
pretty okay at being open with my
friends with my girlfriends like I'm I'm
absolutely fine at
opening up when things get bad there's
probably depths and degrees that I could
go to which I'm hiding from but
I'm
personally probably more open than I
need to be and I probably need to dial
it back now is openness a feminine trait
I know there's an argument there for
guys if I was trying to give advice
finding a group of people a group of men
that you can meet with regularly that
you feel comfortable with a small group
of maybe between sort of four and eight
men's groups in Austin where I am now
are becoming increasingly popular and
rightly so like they really help guys to
open up
um when it comes to opening up to girls
that takes a lot of work I think from
the girl to kind of coax it out of them
to show the guy look I'm not going to be
terrified or
um
like disgusted or
feel sympathy that kills my sex drive
for you if you decide to open up but we
could promise sex after if you share ah
there is that would be enough what were
we saying earlier on about men will do
whatever is required of them to get sex
you share your feelings I will
have sex with you look I I feel like
that's actually probably the best
solution that you've managed to come up
with I really think that works we
figured it out can you fix that it only
took an hour we figured it out yeah what
do you want your role to be I think it's
I think it's a great great clarifying
question like what would you like what
do you think a man's role should be or
what do you want yours to be I mean it's
hard to speak for the complete
Collective but yeah I think the
collective question is hard because it's
difficult to talk about what role do you
want without using archaic ideas of what
it means to be a man and doesn't and
we've already identified that some of
those are a little bit difficult for men
to fulfill at the moment you know like
I'm not no one's going to war no one
stepping outside of their door to
actually like have turf battles with the
person nearby that's that's not
something that you can do aggression
needs to be tuned down in a society
that's become civilized for me my thing
I have spent a good bit of time being
quite confused about what it meant to be
a man to uh be happy to make myself
into someone that I was proud of to be
able to tell the truth that was
something I spent a long time working
out how to do and that I even needed to
do it so for me I my role at the moment
is to try and help people get from where
I was to where I am and I do that
through my podcast I have conversations
with people like Jordan Peterson or
Andrew hubman or Joker willink or
whoever and I do that three times a week
trying to find stuff that I think is
interesting and or useful and having an
outlet for me to be able to reflect on
my own experiences to learn from other
people's and to then create a movement
of hopefully holistic self-improveers
that want to work hard to better
themselves but are going to do it in a
well-rounded way
that to me seems like about as good of a
use of my time as anything because I've
filled nightclubs for a decade and a
half
but never really felt sort of
existentially fulfilled with that I
loved the work that I did but it didn't
it didn't feel like I was fundamentally
making the world a better place whereas
this stuff does you know I hope that
some of the insights about depression or
anxiety or time management or sex or
relationships or whatever we'll leave
somebody in a better place and you know
that's kind of the Golden Rule now of
self-development it's not just about
um treat others as you would want to be
treated it's help others get from where
you were to where you are and if you can
do that if you can help people to go
along those steps then you end up
iterating a society that gets
progressively better and better and
better and better
that seems to be about as good of an
antidote to the challenge and the
suffering that comes along with life as
I can think of like you're going to go
through some hard things
stuff's going to suck for maybe quite a
long time but if you come out on the
other side and you can help people to
get past the pitfalls that you nearly
fell in
that's the biggest middle finger that
you can give to any of the challenges
that you have because not only did it
get you it didn't get you
and you're going to make sure that it
doesn't get other people as well
that seems like a good use of my time
what do you think a female role should
be then like what I heard you say is you
want to help right that's a that's a
masculine trait like you want to inspire
I want to lead what do you think
a future role like the moving into this
new phase yeah women have got more
integrating to do than men I think
um because they have more opportunities
integrating what women have never had to
make a choice between a career and a
family before this is a very novel
situation right and that's because you
very rarely would have had a career now
you have a choice okay like men have had
to make choices between like fatherhood
and career sacrifice all that sort of
stuff for a very long time for the first
time
missing whatever it is because there are
ways supporting the family monetarily
um it's a novel challenge for women that
they need to do a lot of work to try and
get through like I don't
I don't envy the challenge that women
have like I really really don't do you
want to be
financially at the mercy of your partner
or do you want to delay starting a
family
like that's a really rough question
super rough and I there's no existing
archetypes that women can lean into to
go oh well you know the the classic
story of whatever somebody of this lady
from the 2000 BC and she went through
this trials and tribulations but she
managed to balance her law degree with
keeping the family going like it's it's
a very novel challenge that women are
facing
I think that the number of different
directions women can go in provides a
lot of challenges
but can be pretty inspiring because you
now have generations of young girls
growing up to
be able to do different things than
their parents could have done
I would like to say that a nurturing
role this doesn't necessarily mean
staying at home and being with the
family but nurturing members within a
team like there is embodied feminine
wisdom that at the moment is being
thrown out it's like
anything that sounds like caring or
nurturing or interpersonal love all of
that kind of feels like archaic old
misogynistic version of what women
should be but fundamentally that's one
of the strongest capacities that women
have like if you have a woman in a
company that's in a high-powered
position
that is a skill that she should be
leveraging in order to make herself more
effective as an exec to make the
business run more smoothly because the
guys are at a disadvantage when it comes
to that that is her competitive
advantage to use that feminine intuition
to be able to read people's emotions
those things are great like that's power
to me it's not it's not weakness to be
able to use a mothering nurturing nature
in Praise of in service of capitalism
right like it's that I mean you could
argue that that that's maybe not the
most virtuous use of it but it doesn't
really matter like if that's what you're
going to do then embrace the things that
you're good at
um
supporting each other as they go through
this challenge I think is important
because there is a lot of backbiting
amongst women especially given that
women are now competing for status uh
and in Korea and education in ways that
they haven't done before and then
supporting men as well like men need to
support women but broadly I think a lot
of this stuff from women is like if guys
try at the moment it sounds a lot like
mansplaining it's very difficult for men
to try and step up and offer support
without yeah it coming across like I'm
telling you what to do it's like well
and this is where you get resentment
from men because they go look I try to
help and and everybody shouted at me so
[ __ ] you you're on your own and that's
how people end up retreating
um it's a difficult it's like a really
fascinating time for
um gender roles at the moment in the
world for what men and women are
supposed to do do you think that there
is a
um more evolved place that we can get to
uh in Union uh men and women that we
haven't been to before and if you do
what does that look like
oh
I would like to think so but I really
don't know what it would be because we
have
there is there are limits to what we can
change you know we can explain to women
look the earning potential of your
partner is not all that matters the
height of your partner is not all that
matters the education level is not all
that matters into guys the Youth of and
the the dress size of the girl that
you're going out with you know like we
can try to
um
reconfigure our biological
predispositions and what it is that we
like want typically to fit around a new
culture
but you can only push that so far or
else you get into the feminine men on
the front cover of erotica novels and
nobody buys them right like it there is
only so far that you can push it and you
can take it one step at a time some of
the things that I think should happen
that would make positive impacts would
be repedestalizing motherhood I think
that if you put mothers you you hold
them up not as
um Rubes that have been conned by the
patriarchy into basically being a house
slave which is what some media
organizations basically refer to women
that become mothers in early age as
um if you say hang on like this these
are the people that they're literally
creating the next generation of humans
that look after us when we get old they
should probably be praised pretty highly
fathers and fatherhood being looked at
as well as something which can be done
in isolation of a career it would be an
interesting role to try and fill a
friend a friend that had on the show not
long ago spoke about what would happen
if Jeff Bezos said that he was going to
be a stay-at-home dad because Downstream
from that you would have a bunch of
other men that would think oh well maybe
you know if one of the richest guys on
the planet does it maybe it's not so
lame for me to do it
I don't know whether that would work but
I think it's interesting to look at the
roles that uh that fathers have
alongside mothers
those are two of the most important
things but we also need to stop men and
women from fighting with each other that
would be good
um
it's an inflection it's a really
difficult point at the moment it's an
interesting time there's so many layers
there's culture there's traumas there's
just ancestral memory depending on what
you believe in there's culture
flip-flopping all around and you know
women being really overly tough and men
being really overly feminine and trying
to find its Jam you know trying to find
a find a settling spot
that would be good if we could find some
sort of a balance
I wonder what will happen
whether we'll look back in 50 years time
and see this as this sort of really
weird brief blip or whether everything
just continues going from there
um
yeah I I don't know whether men are
being overly feminine at the moment I
think that I think they're being I think
the women being overly masculine is is
probably correct
I wonder whether guys are just being
like apathetic
like I I see more comments now and a
sort of a sentiment of retreatism from
men online like I'm just I'm not going
to engage there's the men going their
own way movement there's the black pill
movement online the red pill movement as
well is also broadly a group of guys
that are retreating from society like
technicals just black pills just out
yeah so Blackpool would be sort of
um seeing that they would call it seeing
the world as it truly is but there's a
lot of people in there that are just
doomers they have no desire to engage uh
then men going their own way is the same
thing retreating from society there's
different factions within all of these
and some of the guys will still engage
my point being that there are more
movements of men who are
just exiting Society like I'm not I I
this doesn't really seem like it's for
me and
women need capable competent Partners
how much of this could be solved through
a commune we start over I see so I see
societies being this sort of rolling
cycle it's like there's so much
turmoil and challenges and it's like
through my head for many years and I'm
like just start the commune just start
it up you know what would the commune
look like oh it's like you know
everybody live in a general Community
you'd share you you wouldn't have money
you would bring your talent like I would
say if you want to come to the commune
what it what is your skill what are you
I mean what would you already oh yeah
I've already I'm um I'm uh I would like
to be assistant Gardener
um the carnivores don't need that but
there will be some that want vegetables
um there will be I'd like to be a
trainer and I would like to be one of
the chefs uh those would be my skills
I'd also perhaps maybe let me add this
one I'd like to do the only other job I
wanted to do before I Was a Race Car
Driver was uh be a psychologist I called
it a shrink back in the day in my head
but maybe some kind of like a counselor
you're gonna cook by day and then you go
to sort people's minds out on an evening
time yeah
I feel like that would work uh I have no
idea I think
um
what would I be good at pretty good
pretty good at running for long
distances so I think I just I just put
me out on a hunt I'll run with the guys
I'll come back I'll hopefully bring
something back I don't know how I don't
know whether whether we're ancestral
here but yep yeah I don't I don't know
whether it would be fixed by a commune I
think there's definitely a movement at
the moment towards like Back To Nature
the whole primal thing that we're seeing
whether it's through nutrition or
lifestyle changes I have a ton of
friends here in Austin that are
considering moving out to some big Ranch
where they all live and 10 families are
going to get together and one of them's
a teacher and one of them's a doctor and
doing what you're talking about but
that's like an unbelievably luxurious
position to be in you need to have what
do you need in this commune like why why
would you say that's luxurious because
they need to be able to buy a Hundred
Acre plot of land okay after that's done
so you have that set up but it's 10
families you know and it's they put it
they go all in they get your cows and
you get your things and your sheep and
your and your wood and whatever you know
hammer and nails
and you know you've got sounds ugly hey
I'm it sounds fantastic but you don't
need money you just need your skills and
you ever everybody brings what they can
and you know maybe it's you know maybe
there's still some money left over and
you need to go to town for various
different things but you know generally
speaking it's sort of this but I see it
being something where okay let's just
say hypothetically it works like this
group starts and then more people come
in and people start having kids and you
know this thing builds and grows and
then all of a sudden it's like there's a
adjacent Villages and they're kind of
everybody you know now you have like
little towns and it's getting quite big
and then you're like man we we kind of
need someone in charge because you know
they're just restarting Society here
you're restarting Society essentially
that's what I'm saying it's just this
rolling societal Loop that happens
whether it's that way or through
catastrophes like it all ends up going
the same way because ultimately at a
fundamental level like greed to takes
over and ego still exists and like you
can't I and I really wonder these are
the things that go in my head I really
wonder if that's just fundamental to
being a human in this you know time
space reality that we're experiencing is
this just part of this reality that we
cannot Escape so it's like how do you
just make peace with it
I do think that a ton of those Dynamics
are just inbuilt yeah I think that I
think that that's just a
a function of having this particular
psychological biological makeup and when
you put humans into groups of 10 that
happens and 150 that happens and 10 000
that happens and 8 billion you get Elon
Musk right like this is the incentives
are not going to change until the
biology changes and what you do is you
try and have social structures like laws
you know that impose the way that people
behave uh or you can have a surveillance
State like the CCP and you can see if
that works so there are a bunch of
different solutions that people are
trying to find in order to come up with
with a an answer to this but I do think
you're right you know if you decided to
go total scorched Earth all Technologies
finished
um and there is a million people left on
the planet scattered across the world
and no recorded history
I think in 20 000 years you see
something that looks an awful lot like
what we have now like it's the same
Dynamics Evolution moves so slowly and
people are going to want Power when it's
offered to them people are going to want
to uh try and take advantage of others
when they can I think fundamentally this
is why
I I admire but think it's ultimately
fruitless for people who
emotionally get very caught up in Big
Picture problems
like you can only impact yourself and
your immediate surroundings and if you
start to try and take huge huge problems
on on yourself without it being a part
of a big team
you're just asking for personal turmoil
because it's you against the world and
that there aren't things as far as I can
see that you can do until you start to
leverage your reach your
um efforts by bringing other people in
but yeah maybe maybe we just do the
commune where would you have it well
that's a great question it would
probably need to be somewhere where you
could have crops all year so somewhere
like
I mean Arizona would be tough probably
Texas as a candidate probably Florida's
a candidate or [ __ ] it Costa Rica
Costa Rica I'll do it I'll do it if you
do Costa Rica yeah there's actually
that's there's a lot of people doing
that I actually just spoke to someone
last night that's kind of starting a
miniature version well there's a bunch
of um I don't know what you call them
like crypto Community people that decide
to start up these weird weird groups of
completely detached from the rest of I
don't know I know maybe that's what
we're both headed for maybe that's what
our future has in stock maybe if all of
that exists if all of this is just part
of our reality then what is what is the
value of our conversation here today
what is the point of this why why what's
the point of bullshitting about all this
what can what ad value are we having
well I enjoyed it I did too there's been
some enjoyment and hopefully people that
have listened have as well the easiest
heuristic I can come up with to work out
whether or not you've lived a good life
is one in retrospect that you're glad
that you lived like if you look back on
your life and you think yeah like I'm
glad with how I spent my time and you go
well oh I can't do that until I'm nearly
at the end of my life and you go no you
can because each week you can look back
at how you spent your last week and
assess whether or not the things that
you did are something that you were
happy you did I'm happy that I spent the
last 90 minutes speaking to you like
that's as far as I'm concerned that's a
good use of my time and
as long as you continue to assess and be
intentional with the way that you move
forward I don't think that you're going
to encounter too many problems
there are things that are outside of
your control but they're outside of your
control so you don't need to worry about
them and there are things that are
within your control and if you learn
from the mistakes and the successes that
you have then you should be able to keep
on moving forward effectively
um what's the point to all of it is a
question bigger than I can answer but
doing stuff that you think is worthwhile
and that you don't regret afterward is
probably a pretty good start it's a
great answer
thank you
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today I
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button